- [Instructor] In a previous video,
we took a look at the labor markets,
and we thought about it in the
context of the entire market
and how it might impact a firm.
So let's say that all of a sudden,
the nation's immigration policy changes
where they're willing to
bring in a lot more folks
who have the skills
necessary to participate
in the labor market that
we are studying right now.
So when that immigration opens up
and more people immigrate
into the country,
what is going to happen
in this labor market?
Pause this video, and also think about
what is going to be the new
equilibrium quantity of labor
and our new equilibrium wage?
And how might that affect
this particular firm?
All right, now let's do this together.
So if all of a sudden, you
have a lot of immigration,
new folks who can participate
in this labor market,
well, that's going to increase
the supply at a given wage.
So if this is the market
labor supply curve,
let's call that sub one,
it's going to shift to the right.
At a given wage, you're
going to have more labor,
so it's going to be like this.
So this is the market labor
supply curve two.
Now what does that do
to the equilibrium wage
and the quantity of labor?
Well, our new equilibrium
wage is going to be lower.
Could put it right over there,
I'll call that W sub two,
with a little star there.
And then we have a higher
equilibrium quantity of labor.
So Q sub two, I'll put
a star right over there.
Now what happens for this firm?
Well, our equilibrium wage
in the market has gone down.
And we assume that this firm,
it is a perfectly
competitive labor market,
so this firm is just going to pay
whatever the market wage is.
And so the marginal factor cost
for the firm has now shifted down.
It is now, this is
marginal factor cost one.
Now this is marginal factor cost two.
And now it is actually rational
for the firm to produce more.
So this is sub one,
and let's call this
quantity of labor sub two.
And so what are other things
that might shift the supply
curve for labor to the right?
We just talked about
immigration into a country.
You could also imagine more people
that are already in the
country being willing
or being able to participate
in that labor market.
For example, in the second
half of the 20th century,
it became more acceptable for women
to participate in the labor force.
And so something like
that where all of a sudden
you have all of these women
entering into the labor force
or into the labor market
for a given market,
well, that could also shift
the curve to the right.
Now let's think about the other way.
Let's imagine that you have
net migration out of a country.
What would happen to the
market labor supply curve?
Well, in that situation,
we would shift to the left like this.
At a given wage,
there would be fewer people
that are willing to work.
So this is the market labor
supply curve.
I will call that sub three.
There's other things that could cause it.
Maybe people's preferences change.
And in this particular labor market,
people aren't willing
to work there as much.
Maybe social norms change
where it's just not cool
to work in that labor market.
Maybe there's another labor
market in another industry
that all of a sudden is paying better.
In that situation, fewer
people would be willing
to work in this labor market.
And so when you shift to
the left, your market wages
go up, so W sub three, just like that.
The quantity of labor
is going to go down, Q sub three.
And then as we see,
if we look at how it
impacts a particular firm,
in a perfectly competitive labor market,
this would be the marginal factor cost
for a firm that's
participating in that market.
So this is MFC sub three.
And then now the quantity of labor
that this firm would
hire is going to go down.
So quantity that the
firm hires, sub three,
put a star over there,
and it has gone down.
So hopefully what we just went through
isn't too much of a surprise for you.
As you see, labor markets
behave very similarly
to the markets for many other things.
If more labor enters into a market,
well, it's gonna shift the
supply of labor to the right.
And if more labor leaves the market
or doesn't want to be in that market,
it's going to shift the market labor
supply curve to the left.